hello nestico my name is Joe Evans John
and with the trade union group here
tragedies of a dream in the air receiver
unite red with injured interesting ?
technology deployment I think there's so
many needs are well today fighting
hunger trying to create when you go to
new services or give people more leisure
time that there's no real shortage of
jobs to do we just have to get organized
for employment as a priority in the
global economy in the moment we've lost
30 million jobs in the last three years
because their financial crisis so we
have to get financial markets together
but there's plenty of there's plenty of
ideas and then you need so I think we
have to harness technology and make
should we use it for human purposes i'm
using a career choice not to destroy
them my family will con- there's no coal
mines any more where they came from and
it took a lot of pain and hardship them
to get those families to turn as
commands to just so they have to have
very active Ollis has to treat that and
also bring a new industries new ideas
you good so that would be my reply to
your important question thank you